i need  every bit of sleep i can get and when  you take an hour from me i am not a  happy person and i'm like so what the  hell is going on why do we even have  this in the first place  daylight saving time okay so it goes  back we're talking about you know 18th  century early 19th century so  uh cities weren't electrified they had  candles you know and probably do we have  whale oil probably but  basically  you were awake in the daytime and slept  at night okay okay come summertime  where the climate is delightful and uh  you don't want to go to bed early  okay you don't want to go indoors early  you want to stay outdoors so they  figured out let's take an hour from the  morning  when you might have otherwise been  sleeping through it an hour of sunlight  and stick it at the end of the day  give you an extra hour of sunlight just  when you want it most  so  seemed like a good idea at the time